[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrar
[Música]
bienvenidos a en primera plana un
programa de radio francia internacional
y de france 24 esta semana les
proponemos un tema realmente
apasionante que mezcla actualidad
filosofía sociedad vamos a hablar de una
de las características quizá que mejor
definan nuestras sociedades
contemporáneas la memoria líquida cómo
vamos pasando de tema tema casi sin
tiempo para digerirlos nos acompañan en
este estudio tal ya volverá politóloga y
lingüista especializada en innovación en
medios de comunicación bienvenida tal ya
gracias melissa ese rato periodista
especializada en cultura bienvenida a
melissa y ariadna canción psicóloga
clínica bienvenida ariadna
la memoria líquida hoy nuestro asunto en
primera plana
fue el célebre sociólogo polaco zygmunt
bauman quien puso el nombre y teorizó
sobre algo de lo que hoy vamos a hablar
lás la sociedad liquida la sucesión de
crisis políticas y económicas sociales y
como nuestra atracción por lo
instantáneo por el consumo rápido van
configurando una forma de ser y de
relacionarnos las redes sociales y el
clic la cultura de titulares el rápido
pasará lo siguiente como si todo fuera
un bien de consumo también la
información o la ingesta de toneladas de
información sin capacidad de análisis le
suena todo esto quizás el reflejo más
potente está en la memoria líquida la
guerra de ucrania borrado todo el mapa
se acuerdan cuando hablábamos de la
pandemia que ya aparece y del ver éxito
seguramente dentro de muy poco nos pase
lo mismo con la crisis y siguiente
repasemos algunas portadas que nos
parecen incluso algunas de ellas lejanas
la cual para nuestra salud hay que dejar
de informarse un poco provocativo el
titular y dos asuntos dos crisis como
ejemplos que ya aparecen borradas del
mapa una de ellas esta portada de
liberación vaga exit el final ya casi ni
nos acordamos de la de meses y años este
trágico divorcio entre la unión europea
y el reino unido- otra del cob y de esta
del país el virus que bloquea el mundo
son dos ejemplos de cómo las crisis
encadenan y de repente la actualidad va
pasando de pantalla casi sin tiempo para
la digestión bueno tal ya les pregunto a
las tres que les viene a la mente cuando
hablamos de memoria líquida lo que me
viene a la mente es como hemos
presenciado y sido partícipes de una
cantidad de cambios de paradigmas sobre
todo en la comunicación pasamos por
ejemplo de la época de la audiencia a la
época del usuario de los medios masivos
a la información hiper personalizada de
la periodicidad al tiempo real de la
escasez de la información a la
abundancia ella la hiper accesibilidad
por supuesto todo esto ha tenido un
efecto social e individual las
relaciones humanas están afectadas
nuestra salud está afectada nuestro
tiempo de descanso está afectado
nuestros sueños se ha reducido nuestras
capacidades cognitivas nos hemos vuelto
más sedentarios y la medida y la
inmediatez con la que conseguimos todo
nos ha vuelto menos tolerantes a la
frustración queremos todo de inmediato
nos hemos vuelto impacientes incluso lo
queremos ahora como si todo fuera un
urgencia no vamos rápido y no sabemos
eso está mexica donde el que le sugiere
el término de memoria líquida melissa a
mí me sugiere la idea de un río
básicamente de un río con una corriente
muy fuerte muy rápida y que en su curso
va dejando piedras y piedras atrás si
nosotros somos en muchos casos o esas
piedras o presenciamos lo que esas
piedras van quedando con el curso del
río a gran velocidad básicamente eso me
sugiere y que queda lo que alcancemos a
rescatar muy visual ariadna que le
sugiere que han sido lo mismo hasta el
cual lo sea pienso en lo líquido en el
agua como aquello que se diluye que
aquello que va pasando y que nos deja
finalmente en una situación de
incertidumbre
donde donde toda la humanidad que está
en transición
es tan incierto y justamente como
hablando en la pandemia me parece que en
el 2020 de la sociedad mostró todo su
exponencial toda su potencia frente al
infinito la memoria líquida es el
reflejo de una sociedad líquida como
decía bauman es el mayor quizá la mayor
expresión de un consumismo desmesurado
que afecta digamos como comentaba al
principio a todas nuestras capacidades
es decir hay una expresión esa memoria y
a partir de ahí todas nuestras
capacidades que son el reflejo de ello
sí se han visto disminuidas y estamos en
un tiempo que nos parece un tiempo de
información de acceso a la información
sin embargo la información como diría
como había dicho el filósofo
y surjan que es un complementario me
parece de bound man la información por
sí sola no ilumina al mundo también lo
puede oscurecer y estamos observando
precisamente un tsunami de informaciones
que se produce en segundo al segundo más
incluso de lo que somos capaces de
digerir de observar en nuestro tiempo de
vida y toda esta información se adiciona
se va se va acumulando no crea
narraciones no crea una historia no crea
una memoria y no queda registrada
tampoco aunque si la hemos ido
registrando y bueno son fragmentos de
actualidad que desaparecen a la
publicación del siguiente y no es
posible detenerse en este flujo no por
eso esta idea del líquido es un flujo
constante de información y los
intervalos de la actualidad son muy
reducidos y además vivimos esta esta
actualidad no nos motiva
más bien se nos presenta como algo
emocional para que reaccionemos por
sorpresa y por por esta fugacidad
desestabiliza la vida no crea ningún
en ningún lugar de referencia no pasamos
de una información extremadamente
violenta a
la imagen de un gato
sin casi una narrativa un relatos y
melissa como periodista hemos caído en
la cultura del clic de la cultura del
titular quienes son los grandes
perjudicados de esta sociedad que
estamos describiendo de esta memoria
líquida en la falta de referentes la
falta de espíritu crítico a la hora de
leer información es la falta de
profundidad de análisis en las
informaciones como lo ves
por un lado está siempre el tema de los
medios de comunicación la
responsabilidad que tienen lo que
tenemos los periodistas y los medios de
comunicación para precisamente construir
narrativas y crear relatos y contar
historias pero efectivamente la
actualidad es la actualidad y los medios
tenemos la obligación de contarla
entonces es decir hay por un lado un rol
por otro lado es verdad que los medios
de comunicación por ejemplo en muchos
casos se toman el tiempo y las páginas y
los espacios en televisión en radio en
prensa de hacer por ejemplo también
perspectivas y seguimientos de temas que
son importantes entonces digamos
hablabas del break sheet si hace ya lo
hemos distante pero hoy todavía por
supuesto vemos las consecuencias del
break city y yo creo que el rol de los
periodistas también es precisamente
tomar esa esa perspectiva y mirar bueno
hoy estamos viviendo esto con qué
perspectiva porque de dónde viene esto
que estamos viviendo entonces eso por un
lado
pero cuando me pregunto así quiénes son
los grandes perjudicados pues por
supuesto en la sociedad del público
nosotros como miembros de la sociedad
pero entonces cuál cuál es la
herramienta o cuál es la herramienta que
le vamos a dar a la gente para para
tener perspectiva para tener para
construir ellos mismos sus propios
relatos pues yo creo que básicamente la
educación sin educación y sin saber que
leemos que no leemos cuál es la
diferencia entre una verdadera noticia y
una ficción pues también se hace
necesario que desde las escuelas desde
la desde la familia desde el desde los
senos de las de la persona sea se
construya también perspectiva se aprenda
a mirarse aprenda a seleccionar qué ves
que no ves y por qué ver y no ver sí
claro esto que estamos describiendo
también el contexto en el que llevamos
hablando desde hace cinco o seis siete
años tanto de las fake news porque las
facebook pueden navegar mucho más
fácilmente por esta sociedad de la
memoria líquida no realmente en saba que
se cree erróneamente que la memoria como
una grabadora que absorbe la información
se registre después uno pudiera buscarla
pero estos errores la memoria funciona
es constructiva y el recuerdo de
reconstructivo entonces esto es que
significa que funciona como wikipedia
por ejemplo no una persona puede
escribir su recuerdo pero también otras
pueden venir y modificarlo y así
funcionan los medios y las noticias si
implantamos recuerdos falsos o erróneos
esto modifica la conducta de las
personas
por eso la fake news o sea es
interesante ver no qué resultado tienen
les voy a hacer una pregunta no sé si
polémica un influencers es un referente
en la sociedad líquida que describió
bauman
a ver quiénes son los referentes
actuales en esta sociedad de la sociedad
líquida tenemos los intelectuales que
marcaban quiénes son ahora los
influencias de instagram
estar porque porque bueno la ahorita que
quien otorga el valor a
quien está otorgando el valor a estas
personas quién los está dirigiendo
enseres que influyen pues somos nosotros
no somos es la multitud y esta multitud
funciona a través de likes a través de
una adhesión que se hace la y que ando
siguiendo los contenidos que fabrica
alguna persona pero como la información
circula sin referencia a la realidad sin
contexto en este careo de permanente
pues la multitud de forma subjetiva está
otorgando en un lugar de importancia a
personas que cree bueno que por el
funcionamiento de hecho de los medios
sociales parecen estar hablando desde el
mismo nivel que hablaban antes los
intelectuales no actualmente
por ejemplo se puede contradecir un
postulado científico una palabra de un
experto con
la historia de una experiencia personal
vamos a profundizar en eso porque me
interesa mucho porque se produce eso
porque hemos encumbrado a un influencer
de instagram quizá porque los valores
ahora de la sociedad es una hiper
representatividad es un valor de la
imagen de la apariencia que
ejerce una especie de tiranía en esta
sociedad líquida melissa como lo ve
yo creo que los referentes son algo
absolutamente personal es decir el
referente a alguien que para mí es
importante porque habla de la música que
me gusta del cine que me gusta de los
libros que me gustan por supuesto no
tiene que ser el mismo referente de
ninguna de las personas que estamos en
esta mesa entonces lo que tú decías es
estoy absolutamente de acuerdo es decir
somos nosotros los que le damos la
validez a un influencer y hacemos que el
logaritmo funcione de tal manera que se
propague frente a otras personas
pero pero quiénes son los referentes de
hoy yo no me atrevería a decirlo yo creo
que que cada vez en ese sentido tal vez
sea algo positivo también de todo este
flujo de información que cada vez
tenemos más posibilidades quien
sea como quien se acomoda a nuestra a
nuestros intereses o por que comulgamos
más con unos que con otros eso tal vez
me parece en medio de lo negativo que
puede llegar a hacer este flujo y este
bombardeo constante de información
también me parece que también te da la
posibilidad de seleccionar y eso es algo
que
es un lujo
el tema de educar nos parece que es
necesaria una educación virtual sobre la
virtualidad y sobre todo para los
adolescentes que me parece que es
el rango de la sociedad que está aquí es
más vulnerable y que generalmente los
adultos nos quejamos muchos de los
adolescentes pero que finalmente son los
adolescentes los que producen los
cambios los grandes cambios y
movimientos en la sociedad pero qué pasa
cuando tenemos como estos los influenza
depende de cuál sea el influencer no no
es lo mismo aquel que propone saltar
sobre los techos que algunos otros que
propone hacer una colecta en argentina y
un caso de santi maratea que han
recolectado más de dos millones de euros
para operaciones o para conseguir en
camiones para apagar incendios entonces
contrarresta la falta de la política ya
ven hablamos de referentes en esta
sociedad de liquida vamos a seguir
hablando de ello a vuelta de la pausa
gracias
directo américa la cita matinal de
france 24 en español de lunes a viernes
desde bogotá con las noticias claves del
día en américa latina y el mundo y los
temas más importantes de la salud la
economía los deportes con invitados y
corresponsales
martynas directo américa en 324 france24
puntocom
[Música]
liberté égalité actual y t
seguimos aquí en primera plana esta
semana hablando de la memoria líquida
como una de las características de
nuestras sociedades contemporáneas lo
hacemos con thalía olvera politóloga y
lingüista melissa serrato periodista
especializada en cultura y arena cancio
psicóloga clínica hablábamos antes de la
pausa de los referentes del mundo actual
serán los influencers en esta sociedad
de la memoria líquida también de las
redes de la cultura de los clics
hablando de la información claro todo
esto no son referentes de peso todo esto
termina siendo diluido de ahí el
concepto de sociedad líquida sin
posibilidad alguna de que nada per en
irse en un momento de hiper
representación de hiper información de
hiper conectividad y con la circulación
acelerada de la que tampoco comprendemos
bien su sentido quizás este sea el
primer problema que no hay una falta de
sentido en lo líquido que nos paramos a
analizar es decir la falta de sentido
crítico respecto a esto que estamos
describiendo hoy porque la falta de
medios de comunicación que hagan el
ejercicio que estamos haciendo no sólo
de comunicación de filósofos de
sociólogos que se detengan porque lo que
nos falta es tiempo el tiempo de la
reflexión el tiempo de la creación el
tiempo de escuchar nos faltan silencios
estamos en una en un ruido permanente
que nos está ocultando parte de nuestra
realidad también las opiniones están
polarizando la gente reacciona de forma
emocional generalmente para estar a
favor o en contra los matices se están
perdiendo yo pienso que debemos apostar
a el silencio a la lentitud porque el
tiempo en realidad es el mismo objetivo
cuantitativamente el mismo que había
antes lo que ha cambiado es una especie
de aceleración del tiempo que no nos
deja tener ese pose ese sedimento
respecto a los temas como lo venderían
melissa pienso más como una
incontinencia al que hay que contestar
rápidamente meterse rápidamente porque
si no uno corre el riesgo de ser
bloqueado o quedar fuera si no logra
responder enseguida entonces no hay un
tiempo no hay distancia no hay
alternancia no hay alternativa y tampoco
hay comunicación
o sea es un mensaje que tiene que haber
una recepción pero no hay un
interlocutor entonces se convierte en
una pantomima de la comunicación de
cuerpos ahí que en realidad todo está
virtualmente voy a hacer un poco de
abogado del echar la culpa
siempre al sistema es culpar al
individuo más si cabe cuando éste ha
tenido posibilidades formativas que sus
padres no tuvieron por ejemplo yendo a
la universidad como lo ven es decir
podemos poner todas las culpas encima
del sistema pero estamos culpando al
individuo está estas lecturas críticas
melissa
lo que pasa es que también va por
supuesto si es el sistema pero son las
demandas también de nuestra época es
decir
tenemos que estar tenemos que estar
felices y optimistas como nos lo pide
digamos la cultura también de la
autoayuda del despertarse con la sonrisa
y saludarte y pensar que todo va a ir
bien en tu día pero también tenemos que
hacer ejercicio para estar en forma y
también está tenemos que ser buenos
profesionales y también tenemos que ser
buenos padres y también tenemos que ser
buenas parejas es decir todo también
pienso que se concentra en todas las
exigencias que le hemos puesto al
individuo y hay una palabra de la que se
habla mucho en revistas y en muchos
lugares también las redes sociales de
las que estábamos hablando
cómo tener cómo obtener la pareja
perfecta cómo ser la chica perfecta como
ser como tener
un culto a la perfección que también por
supuesto si si tienes todo el tiempo
dedicado a ser una gran profesional
hacer una gran nada
cualquiera de los oficios y de las
dimensiones de la vida en la que nos
desarrollamos pues a qué horas también
tienes tiempo de ser crítico de tomarte
el tiempo de reflexionar sobre lo que
está pasando y de ver cuáles son las
consecuencias de la guerra de ucrania en
mi vida personal bachman hablaba no
solamente por ejemplo de la memoria
líquida y el tiempo líquido sino también
hablaba del amor líquido hoy es algo que
que es esencial porque
significa que todos estos este sistema y
todos estos contextos de los que estamos
hablando permea nuestra vida íntima de
una manera asombrosa pero de la que pero
que no la vemos no la percibimos
fácilmente y eso también se ve reflejado
en la falta de lo que llaman compromiso
y en las relaciones la falta de
buscar una pareja por ejemplo estable o
algo así sino que todo es rápido y
consume así como consumes noticias
consumes
personas personas si van quizá él lo
definía como el debilitamiento del
tejido social del tejido social por
todas estas líquida tal y como lo ve a
estas consecuencias se noten en el
directamente del tejido social por
supuesto y por retomar bien surjan que
es cuando yo pienso que es
complementario de bagman él nos habla de
la desaparición de los rituales por
ejemplo ya no tenemos ritos yo no
tenemos lugares comunes a donde asistir
nos hemos distanciado también
desaparecen también las cosas en la
inmediatez desaparecen las cosas el
valor que tiene por ejemplo un alimento
que hemos preparado al que fuimos a
conseguir los los ingredientes que
preparamos que consumimos sentados en
una mesa frente a las personas que
queremos no es el mismo que el que
pedimos por teléfono que el que pedimos
a través de una aplicación y que nos
llega en cinco minutos con las
consecuencias sociales que además eso
puede tener a viernes si siento que hay
una marca mercantilización de la vida
cotidiana hay una pérdida de los
vínculos de los lazos sociales
y es este perdida de los lazos sociales
lo que hace que haya más cosas para
vender entonces hay una activación de
consumo por la falta de lazos aquello
que se rellena que está rellena con
cosas voy a seguir haciendo de abogado
del porque sin embargo el
planeamiento de hoy puede llevar a
pensar que cualquier tiempo pasado fue
mejor no esa famosa frase y sin embargo
las redes también han contribuido a la
democratización de la información al
acceso a la cultura es decir no sé si
podemos hablar de un arma de doble filo
en realidad de que no es ni mejor ni
peor que en otro tiempo feliz pues yo
creo que la nostalgia por los tiempos
pasados es algo que siempre va a existir
no creo que es también sea solamente
consecuencia de esto pero pero sí es
verdad que que sí y lo planteamos hace
un momento no hay tampoco que satanizar
todo todo este flujo de información y
todo es decir tiene consecuencias
negativas como también tiene factores
favorables si estás por ejemplo la
democratización de la cultura entonces
por ejemplo no se irá un espectáculo de
danza de teatro podría ser
sumamente costoso o solamente te
enterabas de que lo había por
revistas especializadas o algo así hoy
en las redes sociales lo puedes
encontrar los horarios de
manifestaciones gratuitas y eso también
por supuesto tiene tiene un lado
favorable es decir acercar también a la
gente a cosas que antes sí evidentemente
eran eran difíciles de encontrar
difíciles de acceder y costosas sí claro
un arma de doble filo tenemos que
considerar también esas partes positivas
porque si no la crítica puede volverse
un poco elitista a la hora de tratar
este tema pues elitista tal vez sea
bueno más bien excluyente desde el
momento en el que pensamos que todos
estamos participando en esta en esta
sociedad y bueno en realidad son muy
pocos quienes generan contenido son
muchos más los que participan
pasivamente recibiendo estos contenidos
sin hablar además de la fractura digital
y de toda la gente que está excluida y
que no solamente son adultos mayores que
también son jóvenes personas que viven
en precariedad que no están participando
para nada en esta sociedad pero están
viviendo las consecuencias porque son
ellos los que nos están permitiendo por
ejemplo un acceso rápido a ciertos
productos son ellos los que nos traen
como hablaba antes del alimento que
pedimos y que queremos que esté cinco
minutos en nuestra casa es la gente
precarizada la que está viviendo esto y
en ese sentido hay una exclusión abierta
yo sé que si las rutas del tsje de
espacio son infinitas para la conciencia
humana entonces como la única solución
de este infinito termina adormeciendo
pero al mismo tiempo o sea creo que es
así si no pensamos en el final si es eso
cómo buscar no pensar en el final no
pensar en la muerte
al mismo tiempo solo que saben morir a
aquellos que encuentran en el arte en la
ciencia ficción en la literatura un
sustituto de lo que le falta a la vida
entonces tiene esta cosa como doble el
equilibrio no sé si el equilibrio pero
si entre estas infinitas opciones si
tenemos la posibilidad de descubrir la
cultura podemos
a continuar lo que pasa que no sé si
esto a lo que se refiere a diana tiene
una profundidad y una carga espiritual
que va en contra de lo que estamos
planteando como memoria líquida quizá
lo que dice es totalmente cierto pero
tiene una profundidad y un sedimento que
es justo el contrapeso lo que no sé que
está ahí pero que cuesta encontrarlo
como 90 líneas y por eso ya no habla de
la desaparición de los rituales de los
espacios de encuentro
no todo lo que es verdad que todo lo que
requiere de tiempo
parece estar desapareciendo pero para
ser un poco tal vez optimista
quiero me gustaría decir que existen
lugares de resistencia ahí
hay lugares allí hay espacios en donde
se preservan las cosas en donde se
genera historia se genera memoria están
por ejemplo todos estos buenos
movimientos es lo uno la slow food slow
fashion que reivindican la lentitud este
espacio de este lugar en donde se
resiste donde donde nos resistimos a la
rapidez y a la desaparición de las cosas
y bueno algo
algo concreto que puedo mencionar sobre
esto es algo que contra todo pronóstico
se ha resistido a desaparecer y es el
libro impreso durante algunos años se
creyó el libro electrónico iba a
destronar completamente al libro impreso
y pues no el libro impreso
sigue siendo
como objeto un referente en la hoja como
punto de referencia de un inicio de un
fin sigue siendo un referente la radio
por la tele siempre pensamos que la
llegada de internet iba a quitar lo
anterior pero hay una transformación más
que una sustitución 100% no como lo de
melissa que trabajar medios y siempre
está esa selección es que la posibilidad
de seleccionar al final es algo
sumamente humano es decir
claro tienes el libro digital pero si
todavía prefieres abrir el libro iii o
leerlo y sentir la textura del papel en
tus manos pues vas a seleccionar eso así
cueste un poco más o simplemente por la
preferencia que tienes frente a ello
pero a su vez yo también diría que
así como hablabas de los movimientos de
resistencia también a pesar de todo hay
cierta conciencia a pesar de que somos
parte de todos creo que bueno hay muchas
personas excluidas como decías de estos
sistemas de información pero también a
pesar de todo y siendo parte por
supuesto de este movimiento
rápido cuando entramos a un café a un
bar pequeño y te dicen no estos avisos
de no tenemos wifi pero hablan entre
ustedes es decir también hay ciertos si
ciertos recordatorios que te dicen sí es
decir el teléfono puedo mirar en
cualquier momento mejor cuéntame cómo
estuvo tu día es decir y hay mucho
placer también en encontrar esos otros
espacios que que fue como el post
confinamiento volvernos a encontrar daba
gusto porque vamos a dejar ahí con esa
idea feliz final de volvernos a
encontrar de volver a buscar esos
espacios nos quedamos con este punto de
optimismo muchísimas gracias a las tres
ya todos ustedes hasta la próxima semana
tienen primera plana gracias